Lindsay Levin: Great to be here with you.
And you started your career at Nestlé
in a beverage factory in Suffolk,
Virginia, I believe, way back when.
And today you run
the largest business division
of the world's largest food company.
Give us a sense of what that means.
Steve Presley: Yeah,
obviously, as you said,
Nestlé is the world's
largest food company.
It's also one of the largest food
and beverage companies in North America.
And I would bet the majority
of the people in the room
have a Nestlé product in your house.
We're actually in 95 percent
of the households in the US
with one of our brands.
And if you think about our brands,
most people know us through our brands
DiGiorno, Stouffer's, Hot Pockets,
Starbucks at home, Coffee-mate
or any of our Purina petcare products.
And so we have a really broad,
vast portfolio of products.
And as we work across that,
how do we bring that to life?
And we bring it to life with 30,000
amazing team members
around the country
that are spread around 119 facilities
in 28 different states
that really are focused
on trying to make our business
and the contributions to the society
much better every single day.
But if you kind of step back
at a global level,
we actually sell a billion Nestlé
products every single day
in 188 countries around the world.
So massive scale.
And to do that, we work directly
with 500,000 farmers around the world,
directly and indirectly over a million.
LL: So that's a lot
of responsibility, right?
We think about food,
we think about farming,
we think about the responsibility
of the agricultural industry
in terms of soil, in terms of water,
in terms of emissions.
Give us a sense of the challenges
that you're now seeking to address
as you think forward in terms
of farming and food.
SP: Sure. I mean, look,
food production in total
accounts for about 30 percent
of total greenhouse gas emissions.
And at the core of that is agriculture.
And for us, that's why regenerative
agriculture is so important.
For us to continue to make progress
on our net-zero commitment,
we actually have to see these farming
practices adopted at more scale.
And when you think about that,
it's easy to say and it's very hard to do.
Just take it to the US level alone.
There’s two million farms in the US,
and for us, we source
over 2,600 agricultural ingredients
from thousands of farms
across the country.
And within that 2,600,
every single crop
has a different challenge
to actually get to regenerative practices.
Carrots are different from apples
which are different from dairy
which are different from beef.
And so the complexity
and scale of that challenge
across that is incredible
because it's not just one solution
that can be applied.
And secondly, as we talk
to our farming partners,
we really talk to our
suppliers to understand.
They're incredibly interested
in this journey.
We try to put ourselves
in the farmers' shoes.
Imagine if this is
a multigenerational farm,
and you're the farmer
that's changing the way
you've farmed the soil
for hundreds of years,
and now there's a better way to do it.
It's incredible risk.
That's where I think for us as Nestlé,
we feel like we have to play
and share in that risk.
And we approach it in this idea
of creating shared value.
And everybody says creating shared value.
But for us, it has to be good for Nestlé.
We’re a for-profit company
and a publicly traded company,
and what we do is focused
around being good for us.
But at the same time, we want it
to be good for the farmers,
good for our suppliers,
good for our consumers
and ultimately good for the planet.
LL: Tell us about the goals
you’ve set for the company.
How ambitious are you trying to be,
how do you prioritize?
SP: Yeah, look, for us on the goals,
we have a net-zero commitment by 2050,
which seems like a long time away,
but as we all know, it's tomorrow.
And if we haven't already started making
progress against that, we're in trouble.
And we're quite proud of the fact
that the progress we made
in the last couple of years,
we're actually beyond peak carbon
and so we're reducing carbon
as we move ahead.
So we’re very focused on that.
And we really approach it
in kind of four key pillars.
We approach it with ingredients
that I'll talk quite a bit about today,
we approach it on packaging,
manufacturing, the conversion process,
and then last, the local
communities that we serve.
And if I can just quickly on each one.
In ingredients, you think about it,
regenerative agriculture has to come
to all those in a way
that brings sustainable change.
And so we’re very focused on that.
And we have to do it
across every single bucket,
whether it's wheat, rice, corn.
And we've got teams and programs
focused across all of those categories.
And for us, we've committed to be
50 percent regenerative-sourced by 2030.
We're well on our way on that journey.
If you think about packaging,
we're very proud of the progress
we've made in packaging.
We've reduced over
half a million tons of plastic
from our existing packaging today,
with so much more to go on that journey.
And then if you think
about the manufacturing
conversion process,
we committed to 100 percent renewable
electricity across all of our facilities,
and we're actually well on the way
on that, we're at 50 percent.
We've been able to reduce our scope
to emissions around that already.
We're invested in two massive
solar farms in Texas
that have allowed us to do that,
and we continue to push that forward.
All of our factories in the US actually
are zero waste to landfill
already today.
And then lastly is in the local
farming communities.
And when we talk
about working with the farmers,
just a couple examples.
You know,
if you think about the work we do
in the Côte d’Ivoire on cocoa farmers,
really it's providing financial incentives
directly to the farmers
to actually encourage these practices
and at the same time encourage
child education and agroforestry work.
So that's just kind of how we think
about how we prioritize across the list.
LL: Now, I want to take you back
to this term “regenerative farming,”
because it seems to me
this is one of these things
everybody's going to self-define
and then we kind of dumb it down
and we don't really know
what we're talking about.
What what do you mean by that?
And how do you hold
yourself to a standard?
SP: I'm sure there have been
much better speakers
and much smarter people
in the course of this session
that have actually defined it
more eloquently than I have.
But when I look at it,
ultimately at the end of every crop cycle,
have we improved the soil
and the biodiversity
of the resources we use to produce those?
And if we have, then we're moving
forward in regenerative farming.
And it's incredibly powerful.
And it sounds a bit academic
or maybe a little far out there,
but really when you get down to it,
some of the practices
are simple as crop rotation,
live root farming, low-till, no-till.
And those are relatively
easy to implement.
Still different and challenging
for the farmers.
All the way to multimillion-dollar
installations of manure systems
that actually can reduce
greenhouse gases on dairy farms.
And so the scale and complexity
of the application of solutions
is very different as we work through that.
LL: And what are you doing to actually
advance those practices?
SP: You know, when we think about it,
I think the best way to bring it to life
is maybe focus it on a product.
And we're in Detroit,
which is a great pizza city.
And so let's talk about pizza.
Every great pizza
starts with a great crust
and the crust in DiGiorno,
we're making an announcement today,
where we're investing
in over 100,000 acres
of wheat farming in the US
with our partners
to be able to produce enough wheat
to double the production
required for DiGiorno pizza.
And so we'll have regenerative
wheat through that.
And then you move to the tomatoes.
Today, it’s not about getting more farms
to actually move to regenerative practice,
and tomatoes, the majority of our tomatoes
are already regeneratively farmed.
And so it's about external verification.
So we're working with an external firm
called Leading Harvest
that's actually help us
not only just, one, we’ve already
got the farmers doing it,
but how do we verify it over time,
how do we continue to do that?
So we work through the tomatoes
and I think really good
progress in that space.
And then when you go to dairy,
dairy is one of the toughest ones
and we're quite proud,
we were the first company to join
the US Dairy Net Zero Initiative,
and we have live farms
working in California today
or around the country today
that are really focused
on applying these practices
that can get to net zero
emission for a dairy farm
and at the same time, is it economically
viable for the farmer?
And we're really proud
of the progress we're making
with some of our farming
partners out there.
And then the last one is meat,
and we all love a good pepperoni
or topping on the pizza.
And when you go to meat,
we actually have the largest partnership,
it's early days, we're just
moving ahead with it,
but the largest private
partnership with Cargill
and the National Wildlife
and Fish Foundation
to actually have regenerative
ranching practices in over 15 states.
So as you kind of think through the pizza,
you can see that it touches
every single component,
and every single one
is a different application and solution.
LL: So there's a lot
and this is difficult.
Where are you not moving
fast enough yet?
SP: Where are we not moving fast enough?
You know, for us, I think clearly,
when you go to try
to drive this kind of scale,
it's not about one farm.
It's about the farming ecosystem
in total that has to change.
So we need to move at scale
to be able to do this
across not just our business,
but if we're really going
to move the needle,
we have to do it at industry level.
And so I think just the pace of the change
where we'd love to see
that move a little faster.
I think secondly maybe is in packaging,
when I look at packaging
and recyclability,
we know the recycling infrastructure
is woefully insufficient in the US.
It's why we've leaned in
pretty aggressively.
We’ve invested with partners like
Closed Loop to support infrastructure,
and also we support kind of responsible
extended producer responsibility
to actually help build that
because we know that we can't make all
the recyclable products we want.
There is no infrastructure to do it.
So at the end of the day,
it doesn't get done.
And so I'd say that's an area
where we're really focused.
And just lastly, I think
the tempo and urgency
across the entire industry complex
is one that we've got to pick up the pace.
We've got to move much, much faster,
not just to achieve our goals,
but to make the kind of difference
we want to make.
LL: So just to close, Steve, what can
and should we expect from you all?
SP: Look, I think you'll continue to see
incredible commitment.
By 2025, we will have invested
3.6 billion dollars in these practices
across the world for Nestlé.
It's an incredible investment
but we believe it's the right investment,
because ultimately,
when you look at our business,
we're a food and beverage business
that we make products for you
and your families and your pets
to enjoy every single day.
And those start with great ingredients.
And that investment for us
is actually about a business decision
that, we've been around
for over 150 years,
if we're going to be around
for the next 150,
we need to make sure we have great quality
ingredients for that period.
And so that investment actually
helps us ensure that.
So what you can count on
is we'll continue to drive that
across all of our complexes.
But most importantly, what I'm proud of,
is you can count on the company
and all the people that work in it.
There's 30,000 in North America
and there's almost 300,000 worldwide
that are absolutely committed
to making progress every single day
against one of those commitments.
SP: Steve, thank you
very much for joining us.
SP: Thanks for having me.
(Applause)